a New Jersey family is in a holiday
battle with local officials over an
extravagant nightly Christmas display
the opposed e's have decorated their
house with tens of thousands of dazzling
lights during the past 15 years now it
has attracted hundreds of tourists but
some neighbors argued that the spectacle
creates chaos now the family faces
thousands of dollars in fines Don Dahler
is at the house in old bridge New Jersey
with the Christmas light fight good
morning Don hey good morning each year
Tom Abruzzi spends about two months
putting together this really incredibly
elaborate display he figures he's
invested about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars over the past decade or
so but now the cost of bringing all that
joy is about to skyrocket how long have
you been doing this
this will be our 15th year it's a
tradition like no other
for Tom approves e the Christmas holiday
is his time to shine why do you do it
why why such a commitment of time and
money because I just love Christmas
but this year the love is not shared
with some members of his own community
who've taken their fight to the mayor we
have to make it safe I don't have a
choice Old Bridge mayor Owen Henry says
the improves these neighbors have safety
concerns like heavy foot traffic minimal
street parking and accessibility for
first responders I actually had the
street all blocked all the lights don't
just hike the electricity bill city
officials say the approves ease must pay
a three thousand dollar fine every night
he sets up a light show for visitors
they want me to pay for the police and
they also want me to pay for shuttle
service from a private parking lot and
and bus people in that they want me to
pay for it what are the neighbors think
about this some like it some don't what
do you think about this display I think
it's fantastic what he does for the
community everything is great ready to
go
the attraction gained national attention
in an episode of the great Christmas
light fight
where families deck out their homes to
compete for cash
the approves II say it's never been
about fame or money the family collects
visitor donations to fundraise for a
charity that houses severely injured
veterans we started taking donations
probably around six years ago so we've
probably had probably over thirty
thousand dollars but if the approves
refused to pay the fines taxpayers their
own neighbors may have to foot the bill
which would force old bridge to pull the
plug on the show do you think they're
gonna be able to shut you down though if
they shut me down they're gonna have to
talk to my attorney so you think this is
a First Amendment right this is my First
Amendment free speech free speech and
free religion the abruzzi say that they
will foot the bill for the security for
at least the first few nights they've
started a GoFundMe page the goal is
$75,000 but even if they don't reach
that goal they say these lights will go
on starting this Saturday night John
almost as bright as the Star of
Bethlehem Don how much what's the what's
the bill on the electricity for those
things yeah that's the real question cuz
really at night we he was testing it
last night and we saw it lit up it was
incredible but a lot of these are LEDs
they don't draw as much power as you
think his electric bill per month at the
height of the season is about $1300 I'm
just thinking of the scene from
Christmas vacation vacation
Clark is Coors well lights the house up
that's all I see one of those bulbs goes
bad I want to replace one I like that
mr. Busey loves Christmas that much and
he's in the spirit they go for it my
friend go for it